4000 employés 2500 moteurs par jour 210
tonnes de métal coulé quotidiennement
et pourtant vous chercherez en vain à la
française de mécanique
les cheminées noirâtre ou la laideur
uniforme de l'ancien pays minier on veut
montrer ici que l' usine de demain
peut-être plus humaine en combattant la
monotonie non seulement dans
l'architecturé mais aussi dans le
travail est particulièrement là où il
est souvent le moins qualifiés et le
plus déshumanisant sur les chaînes de
montage
premier objectif rendre l'opérateur la
plupart du temps à nos os moins
tributaire du pas de chaîne c'est à dire
de la vitesse à laquelle les pièces
défilent devant lui pour cela on a
découpé la longue chaîne traditionnelle
en plusieurs mini chaîne autonome
préparation des pièces habillage dans
des serres dans un deuxième temps à
l'intérieur de chaque chaîne on a
regroupé les opérations pour permettre à
chaque ouvrier d'accomplir une tâche
plus longue donc plus variés on n'a pas
toujours le même travail
c'est ça qui est bien on peut aussi bien
sur scène que par ailleurs aussi bien
travaillé
sur les culasses que sur les rares faire
un montage c'est comme ça qu'on apprend
bien le travail par mois pénibles mais
plutôt plus intéressant parce que
revenir j'en ai plus tôt
on n'est pas tout seul à travailler et
quand on est ensemble on sait qu'on
savait et s'il ya quelque chose qui
touche quoi faire mais on fait quoi ce
qu'on a voulu éliminer ces ceci toutes
les 40 secondes cette opératrice répète
un nombre limité de reste au rythme de
défilement de son chariot sur la chaîne
d'habillage désormais en aval sur cette
chaîne ont effectué des tâches
d'enrichir dont la durée a atteint 7 et
même 13 minutes 13 minutes c'est déjà la
norme pour tous dans le nouvel atelier
gît sur le moteur de la r21 là aussi
efforts architectural et enrichissement
des tâches sont liés ici quatre mini
chaîne d'habillage sont répartis dans un
atelier en forme de h
entre ces chaînes des stocks tampons
pour stabiliser l'écoulement de la
production et permettre à chaque chaîne
de travailler à son propre rythme une
source d'autonomie supplémentaire qui
permet la constitution d' équipe où
chacun va réaliser non plus une mais la
totalité des opérations nécessaires ici
le montage du bloc cylindres l'opérateur
n'est plus attaché à son carillon
il peut en contrôler la marche à chaque
stade de son travail voilà le bloc
cylindres est prêt il va partir vers la
zone de stockage grâce à cette zone
tampon
l'équipe chargée de la suite des
opérations peut travailler à un rythme
différent de celle qui la précède
premiers résultats pour le chef de
l'atelier gide il travaille dans
l'automobile depuis 17 ans la création
de l'esprit d'équipé synonyme de
responsabilités donc de qualité alors au
niveau qualité ils se sont beaucoup plus
motivés avec dans ce contexte là que
s'ils travaillent en micro opération il
a un engagement de sa personne y signe
son produit lui même
et tous les mois on a des réunions où on
fait un point qualité où on lui donne
ses résultats donc il connaît sa
position est la position de son groupe
contrairement à ce qui se passait il ya
quelques décennies les gars qui étaient
en chaîne on avait peut-être le nez sur
le mur avec de grandes chances qu'il se
sentait complètement embrigader tandis
qu'ici maintenant ils ont un horizon qui
est beaucoup plus ouvert et une
possibilité d'évolution
attention des syndicats il ne faut pas
confondre innovation et évolution la cgt
parle de tape-à-l'oeil
le nouvel atelier il est vrai ne sommes
pas encore en pleine production
elle craint une augmentation sur l'oise
décadence de son côté la cfdt
majoritaire
sans condamner le système réserve encore
son jugement
est ce que réellement enrichissement
lorsqu'un ouvrier au lieu de faire mille
fois les mêmes gestes fait 200 fois cinq
gestes différents donc on voudrait faire
croire aux gens que l'or leur tâche est
enrichi alors que bon bah en fin de
journée la pénibilité est la même alors
s'il est trop tôt pour affirmer que la
française de mécanique c'est déjà lusine
de demain s'enchaînent 200 jaurès il
reste qu'elle représente déjà il n'est
de coupure avec le passé c'est un
premier pas important
[Musique]